he's either growing up he's so what I
found out actually through this fight
that we just had he goes even with your
mom you're your grandparents I've always
just been a fact person I only state
facts that's how I communicate you want
to talk you want me to talk to you like
your mom talks to you I can't do that
so you you can't expect me to adjust I'm
old you have to adjust for me
so my dad equates love through you know
he provided for us Allah says so that's
like Korean it's very standard Korean
because she doesn't think he might hear
it
she thinks that what I'm doing is South
Asian oh that's no middle-aged it's pure
love
yeah no I'm getting it slowly now yeah
yeah now I've watched shoes go buy shoes
I got it [ __ ]
take my cards I'm shopping I love you
Yeah right you want whatever dinner you
want you got it but do I ever capitalize
no you don't what I'm saying is that
he's good because he offers that I never
take it yeah and because that's not
that's how I express it I was different
love languages we've talked about this
everybody receives and perceives love in
a different way so for me it's about
affection like I need why are you hurt
you want to be a hell like a baby I
could be watching West world I could be
doing another [ __ ] crucible thing on
the destiny you know me but you got to
do this and that's all girls I love you
I'm fighting I guess you know I'm I'm
saying you sold me a false dream then
you stupid [ __ ]
because in the beginning [ __ ] look at
me right now now it's not on hold on in
the beginning of our relationship David
all he wouldn't let me go
he was so touchy-feely
you just cling I mean I straight-up
thought he was a stage five clinger like
he would next everything I did he was
attached to me at the hip now all of a
sudden like we don't touch
we're not homies anymore we can't hug I
can't ask for a hug what's Trump's
wife's name Milania Milania okay let me
tell you something right now and
everyone in this room listen to me right
now when he first dated Milania he
pulled out all the stops got the [ __ ]
pregnant you got to grab the [ __ ]
that's when he said it to her pregnant
right so he presented her with a
different light and then a couple years
later you gotta grab the [ __ ] I don't
know the [ __ ] you're saying what does it
even mean what I'm saying would tell you
right why okay this is that we want to
get you know like I love her like she's
great to talk to I can tell that we get
along but I want to keep her for myself
well I'm gonna take her off the market
right and so I'm gonna do everything I
can to make that happen
yes over the years you reveal other
things you mean how I really have you
know but that by that time it's too late
we got three cats and a dog I'm not too
deep in do you feel like you were duped
then she was a minute I do [ __ ] do
but every guy dupes our girl yeah I
think so every guy you know three years
and girls looking like that little team
that you do you didn't used to do that
yeah I can do it now because your mind
yeah yeah I had a really [ __ ] up dream
and this is how I know I love you okay
this is gonna I don't know what this is
Oh baby Davie Davie you're about to hear
some [ __ ] you said I can call you
whatever you want yes I mean I want for
the rest of our life you're Davey I like
you tell me what this means
melena baby the melon I interpret my
dreams okay okay so I had a dream you
know we had a guest to your chris
wachowsky um I had a dream that he
cheated on me with chris wachowsky
speeding oh oh and then chris wachowsky
in everybody Judd Apatow and everybody
came to attack Bobby and I defended him
and I said no he didn't cheat with her I
was with him on the night of night of
night of and I basically painted a
picture as if he didn't even in fact he
did but he didn't cheat because I didn't
want him to lose the job on love exactly
why you're with that [ __ ] right there
but I was crying I was heartbroken he
cheated on me but you still pull them
out because you protected me and that's
being called a good person in a real
woman okay I'm the beta his J you know
and you you you you went to bat for me
even though I did the wrong thing and
that's why you can get shoes tomorrow
he's been he's been telling me I can buy
shoes for three years I had yet to use
any of his money a single dime to buy a
single pair of shoes she has to do is
this why is that because I'm always
asleep what kind of my waking up lately
5:00 p.m. 5:00 6:00 p.m.
yeah right I'll buy your shoes tomorrow
everyday we don't know if all you have
to do this lady I don't want your
[ __ ] life I'm just saying I'm just
letting you know that this can happen
tomorrow you wake up you call your
friends yes let's go shopping
you grab my [ __ ] you know my codes for
my ATM you have all my credit cards and
go [ __ ] crazy well I also give a [ __ ]
that's because I love you but you won't
take it
I've never honestly us you can ask him
I've never he said take my credit card
I've never used it to go on a shopping
spree it feels I feel weird what would
you have used my credit cards to buy
when we when we are together that's not
true
we're together they're gonna stop stop
it right now what about the two jackets
you got from Stu see those were my
that's my money I use my money for that
what the [ __ ] you laughing at Matt my
friend I know look at me right now what
are you cackling about exactly cuz you
calling Ralph or using your card I made
a mistake just and you cancelled in my
face friend I'm sorry man I'm sorry okay
look at me right now
do you watch yourself oh you know I do
hey Melonhead you can do whatever you
want
groceries that's what I use it for
grocery whatever what nutrients extra
more I give hers of life sources of life
Yeah right water vitamins nutrients
things to make her shelter live shelter
companionship Tomica dog right so I did
all those things
yeah because that's the law no one's
saying you're not a good provider that's
it you're a great provider I'm not gonna
hold you know how to hold me so what's
what's your love language then my lung
let lung language my language is
affection and time so it's just this
quality time with quality time so he
can't be on his phone right yeah I'm on
engaging but it's like basically it's a
problem yeah he has problems I have
massive I'll admit and I'm gonna get
emotional
well when I'm getting emotional
do me a favor wipe that smile off your
[ __ ] face man who me yeah I'm just
kidding I wasn't getting him but I just
yeah yeah I have problems hmm I've been
a little depressed lately because I've
been playing a lot of video games
destiny thank you thank you so much
Davey
this is the best ad and um I've been
waking up at 6 p.m. mm-hmm I went last
night
six P six Donuts six Donuts yeah I
haven't eat California doughnuts all day
I was six I went to the communist toward
to do another podcast I came over here I
haven't eaten a single thing
my body's breaking down okay so I might
say something or behave in ways that's a
little erratic I might cry for no reason
but thank you and you know what I like
about you Dave you're very [ __ ] quick
very fast very slow over here very slow
very you didn't get beat enough that's
yeah you didn't hear enough that's true
okay you only gotta fish to push only
fish hooks so the question for you I
love you but I'm not done yet
I hate when he does that I love you only
comes when it's like I love but I love
you
what's your [ __ ] girlfriend's name
I'll give your name Vasili Cindy Cindy
that's all I want to know you know what
right there that was a big step for you
and I encourage you to do more so in the
future but I am listen I'm not we're not
blood-related okay your guardian angel
your Dreamweaver
how about Dreamweaver yeah yeah and
almost of your life coach mhm I really
need to know everything I know and
that's the way you and I are gonna
[ __ ] get closer yeah
because right now you're becoming friend
but you're more of an acquaintance going
backwards yeah meals with you really
because I don't know what your girl full
girlfriend's name is yeah and you're not
see see what your smile your smile your
smile yes right I can't smile I'm the
captain of the ship okay fine
and this is the boat okay do you guys
all know that no Rosa I'm standing up
right now okay Bryce
all right everyone I'm telling you right
now I'm sorry
I'm in a mood okay we're all equals as
human beings okay when God if when Jesus
Christ comes back to earth right we're
all me and Tom Hanks same level okay
okay he's a little bit you guys they go
to heaven first
okay we're out but in this [ __ ] room
is a ship and I'm the captain okay baby
I'm motivated no I don't know I'm not
done
oh I want everyone to clap okay right
and everyone just say at the same time
when I count to three
you're the captain and my Savior oh my
god oh my god everyone clap right yeah
three two one you're the captain and my
Savior
Wow that's the ticket and that's the
good stuff
yeah David was telling me before the
show he actually met you when he was 18
I don't remember you were at Riverside
and you did a stand-up comedy show and I
saw you now I remember that yeah I don't
remember because that show particularly
was crazy right there was a lot of
people there yes you [ __ ] killed it
yeah and it was just like the energy I
remember going oh
he grabbed my RNA he stood he told him
put his hands up like this
yeah he's him as a stripper pole extra
butt naked and he harassed him yeah and
I was sorry for college yeah oh [ __ ]
yeah that was pretty [ __ ] awesome
yeah you you you use what you have
yeah you know what if there's a quote of
the week that's it
you usual you have and I want people to
really memorize that
[Music]